e
open the meeting of Health Human
Services oversight committee for Friday
the 22nd of November 2024 and would the
clerk please call the
role representative Pearson here
representative Weber here representative
Edwards here representative King here
represent Merchant here represent
McDonald
representative
Murphy Senator
gray Senator
rosenwall and Senator
avard Senator Rosen Ball's uh people
sent an excuse ahead of time so it's an
excused absence okay thank you approval
of the minutes from October 25th regular
meeting you should have gotten them by
email any questions I'm looking for
approval I'm also looking for
them well they were they've been buried
they would look like this I need to get
my copy yes it's rapped on thank
you I've already looked at
it is that a motion to approve
uh motion and second to approve any
further
discussion all in favor I
opposed DHHS commissioners update the
dynamic threesome of Deputy Commissioner
Dr uh Melissa
hen our I I don't say old friend but
friend of many years standing Henry
Litman and Wendy Alman and everybody
come on up eventually uh good morning uh
Marissa hen Deputy Commissioner thanks
so much uh chairman Pearson I think what
we'll do is I'll give a a little
overview of our play in three acts and
then uh invite the different uh
individuals from the Department to come
forward since we have uh a nice uh array
of updates for you today um so here's
what I'm thinking uh is that we will
first have I'll give a little overview
and then we'll have them come up we'll
first uh talk about the system of care
for aging um for healthy aging
specifically by having um associate
commissioner Chris sanello um as well as
our bureau chief Wendy Alman um from the
bureau uh for adult and Aging Services
come up give a couple minutes then we'll
have Henry Litman um our uh director uh
of the division for Medicaid services as
well as associate commissioner an Landry
come up to talk about both Community
re-entry as well as Medicaid um for uh
through the schools and then I will
close out with a little bit of an update
on the two reports that you requested
information on does that the room till 3
P.M okay my hope is that we can actually
be super efficient and maybe keep all of
this to 10 or 15 minutes to avoid folks
um needing to be here all day so with
that
um I will invite uh Chris anello and
Wendy Alman to come join me here and
I'll get a third seat so we can all be
up
together we need a much larger
testifying table with more
microphones you the there I'm yeah I'm
like attorney Williams can you make that
happen what that I believe that you just
have to ask for it and you shall receive
seek and I shall find I'll do it
good morning um like um Deputy
Commissioner said I'm Chris Sello
associate commissioner joined here by
Wendy Alman who is our bureau chief for
adult and Aging Services formerly known
as adult and El elderly and Adult
Services so um in the last in our
current bium the system of care for
healthy aging was included in hb2 and
this provided the department a
significant opportunity um to strengthen
our system of care for adults um who are
aging in the state of New Hampshire and
so Wendy did submit the annual report um
to um this committee November 1st but I
just asked her um to kind of just give a
high level overview of the work and what
we're
doing and let us know what the document
looks like because we have lots of them
yes hi uh Wendy Altman bureau chief for
the Bureau of adult and Aging Services
um with you today um just really quickly
is a very highlevel overview snapshot of
information that we've provided as part
of the annual report just to talk about
the progress that we've made um over the
last year and a half for system of care
for healthy aging and um first we wanted
to just point to the visual uh diagram
um this is part of our annual report but
it's also something that we worked
collaboratively on with the Commission
on Aging to really develop a visual um
to describe how we are also part of the
DHHS uh road map as well as the elements
and vision for system of care we talk a
about that a little bit more in a little
bit more detail in the annual report but
the focus that I wanted to try to get to
today is around what we've completed in
that progress and what we're doing next
um we uh completed um over the last year
and a half um implementation of the rate
increases that were part of hb2 for our
choices for Independence waiver program
we also implemented and began to
operationalize last January
um the eligibility changes that were
part of the bill we've reoccured our
aging and disability Resource Center
contracts and included um several
elements within the system of care into
their
contracts yes and aging and disability
Resource Center is formerly known as
service link um so we're um
transitioning uh how we identify with
the work that we're doing at the Aging
indust disability Resource Centers and
transitioning the name we also began to
implement person centered counseling
within the Aging and Disability Resource
Center contracts and hired two the full
two the two full-time staff um at the
bureau um to oversee um coordination and
oper operationalizing the person Center
Counseling Services we conducted a uh
CFI rate study my choices for
Independence waiver rate study um and we
issued that at the end of June at the
end of fiscal year
24 and we incorporated the elements that
um are included within that uh rate
study in terms of the fiscal impact and
what our recommendations are and our
prioritized needs for the budget um for
the agency
request we also began phase one of our
Bureau name change we've made uh efforts
to change many of our documents and
outward facing Communications related to
the name change with it uh finishing up
with the budget request and elements
that have to um be changed
there and we also uh filed our
application to amend our DHHS
1115 demonstration waiver to include
presumptive eligibility for the choices
for Independence waiver program that was
submitted in the spring and we are the
status of that is that we are currently
waiting for the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid to review that Amendment um and
we will engage with them once they um
start doing
that uh in terms of next steps things
that we're working on currently and will
be uh finishing up before the end of the
fiscal year we are finalizing what's
required as part of hb2 in the system of
care which is uh a system of care plan
and vision um we are currently working
with a vendor to develop the draft of
that now and expect that to be done
within the next two months we are
submitting a state plan amendment to uh
procure Medicaid administrative claiming
for aging and disability Resource Center
activities which will increase um our
federal
dollars that can contribute to the work
that is being done um we will complete
our all of our information technology
enhancements and part of the annual
report includes um some detail in terms
of what those enhancements are and what
to be expected um we will also be
submitting a choices for Independence
waiver Amendment and we will start that
process after the New Year um to do that
and as part of our
2627 budget request as part of DHHS we
are monitoring and providing education
um on the agency and prioritize needs
that the bureau
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question and welcome back
um I just had an overall question about
the CMS waiver process because if you
submit it in the spring and are still
waiting for an initial response that
seems a little dilatory on their parts
is that is that H how long it normally
takes for a waiver because I thought
that they went most of them went through
quicker than that and
I'm just wondering I wasn't sure if
Henry might Henry might have some more
detail on that but I think it I think it
depends on what the request is and and
the um staff within CMS who are
reviewing it and what they have in Q
also to review Henry Lipman we've got
mics
on yeah this is an Engineers WIS you're
welcome you're welcome to any of those
um so I guess the answer is that we have
a commitment that we're going to um you
know we've submitted it um there's an
extraordinary number of of 11:15 waivers
being done I'm going to be talking about
what what we got in place we had uh to
prioritize what could get approved um
back in uh July and um this one was one
that they needed more time to work
through because it's not one they
usually give where versus the others
were ones that we already had to be
renewed and were um if you will higher
priorities for the administration to to
get in place um but um I just met with
the
last week with the head of the the
waiver group to make sure that we're
still um expecting it back in July they
told us it would probably be within uh
calendar year 25 that we would see it um
and that's I think I think we'll get it
um and it's just they're they're just
overrun at this moment in terms of all
the things they're trying to do plus
with the change in
administrations y would you accept a
recess appointment equivalent
be happy to do it only if I just make M
Mr chairman I just wanted to make it
very clear that I was not implying that
anybody in our department was at all
dilatory I just just seemed to me like
seemed an extraordinary amount of time
for the federal government to respond so
thank you for the explanation I get it
you're most welcome I think we've been
treated pretty well as a state in terms
of getting things done like with the
dental U waivers that we needed and um
they've they've tried to work with us
and some they have to pay attention to
you I think yes representative
Edwards thank you for that and uh
putting on uh the division three hat for
a little while I I I I love the kind of
the conceptual visual information aspect
of this but it would be nice um uh and I
know that you have tons of spreadsheets
that Mr White's to show us but it would
it would be useful in January or
February whenever I guess it's going to
be February when we get together to see
something like this to and to show us
what kind of general fund impact that
these slides have and uh you know on
this this circle of life you know where
we're kind of spending money just to
just to take this nice conceptual
outline and give it some life in terms
of what kind of res resources are being
consumed in this this is this this could
be just a little bit of of resource or
could be a ton of resource and that that
that's really going to be important
going into this next budget cycle
definitely yeah and so I'm not asking
for feedback now I'm just telling you I
I think this let's see this again in the
future but but associate some resources
with it
please representative Merchant don't
throw away your lawn signs with we want
you back in two years thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for this presentation as
well one of the things that we're
experiencing here in the state is an
aging population and also when I talk to
people there's more desire to stay at
home AG in place which is non
institutional care so trying to tie this
all together goes back to repr of
Edwards is looking for resources because
ultimately if we have an aging
population when you build the budget is
we have enough resources into the
homebased care that we put in
institutional care because if that's
where people want to stay I'd like to
encourage us to do
that it's also less expensive it is
representative Edwards I do have a a
supplemental thought um I I think for
the second year I'm going to be wanting
to take a look at if there are
additional services that we want to
migrate into a Managed Care structure
and so I think one of the conversations
we could have in February would be this
is sort of a a roll your own State doing
this for ourselves kind of thing what
what would it look like if we were to
try to put this into a Managed Care
structure so and and again the resource
implications of that um thank you thank
you any further
great all right so as promised up next
we'll have associate commissioner Ann
Landry and Medicaid director Henry lman
on community re-entry as well as the U
work good morning anry associate
commissioner Henry Litman for the record
Medicaid
director and we just wanted take a few
minutes this morning to share some
exciting news um as along lines that the
Medicaid team along with Behavioral
Health Team and Department of
Corrections excuse me can I ask you to
speak louder for these elderly ears sure
sorry I do my voice does stop I'll be
better voice um so for the past couple
of years we've had a dedicated team
working on an exciting program that is
focused on the re-entry into the
community from the for the incarcerated
population for the adults and since July
due to a mandate from the federal
government we've also been working on a
program to um focus on reintegrating
youth back into the community um for
those who are eligible 18 to 21 and then
21 to 26 from for former foster care and
so this has really been an incredible
joint effort between the Department of
Health and Human Services and the
Department of Corrections and within the
Department of Health and Human Services
it's been a close collaboration with the
division of Medicaid services division
of Behavioral Health Services Division
of children youth and families along
with our eligibility team um in division
of economic supports so it really
highlights the the important work that
we're doing together to ensure that
these individuals receive Medicaid
benefits um pre-release and then back
into the community and with that I'll
make sure you can hear me well y okay
good um so I think probably uh those who
serve on in the house and oversee County
are familiar with sort of the inmate
exclusion where um Counties have to pick
up medical cost because with only
certain exceptions they only cover
inpatient care this is actually um a
chance for um both state corrections and
for the um County corre uh jails to be
able to tap into um some additional
Federal funding to support um the
successful transition um from
incarceration to um the community you
know the state uh and Counties have done
work with the council state governments
that you know one of the major reasons
people have recidivism is is difficulty
maintaining sobriety over with mental
health issues um so uh commissioner
Hanks approached us
uh before there actually were criteria
to apply for this Grant and asked us uh
if we would make a waiver request a
special request at the time um to obtain
an 1115 waiver um and basically um we
did apply in 2022 in 2023 the federal
government came out with um actually
criteria to apply we had to adjust what
we had submitted um in July we receiv
received that so the the net effect of
it is that for adults
um um that during the 45 days prior to
release um Medicaid can come in and
provide support for um mental health and
sud um by starting to get the
relationship and actually have U Managed
Care visits if you will like with from
the Mental Health Center or others uh to
address those issues so that um upon
release they've already have those
relationships established we can support
some of the cost of the those
medications um during that 45-day period
but probably probably one of the biggest
savings and biggest success factors I
think is that upon discharge that uh the
Medicaid Program can the federal
government will kick in to pay for a
30-day supply of medications so that you
know when they um they leave they don't
end up in emergency rooms or you know
seeking relief that they need to support
either um a mental health or or sud
condition
um so that's sort of the adult program
um the idea also is to make sure that if
they're eligible for Medicaid um to get
that set up so again medical reasons
mental health reasons pharmaceutical
reasons aren't the reason for reiis and
as I mentioned earlier the council state
governments who studied a lot of New
Hampshire's experience and you know Hank
own um experiences a lot of those reism
are related to you know health
conditions so that that uh we were among
uh the first states in the country to
receive that waiver um we'll probably be
second in the country to be implementing
our we're um looking to implement um
in January starting January with the
state facilities um because we've been
working for a long time as uh associate
commissioner Landry mentioned um and you
know I think we're fortunate to have um
and commissioner Hank someone who is you
know actively engaged in wanting to do
this and and um so that's helpful so as
uh commissioner Landry mentioned before
you move on can can I make a qu ask a
question about what you said so far so
the idea is when somebody is released
there's 30 days of medications
supplied
um sorry uh 30 days of medication
supplied and many presumably will not
have a job to go to or so they would
qualify for at least Medicare perhaps uh
Medicaid Medicaid okay some will qualify
for Medicare if they're older being
released got it and that would mean that
um you got a 30-day window to get them
into this
otherwise don't they can't afford their
medications and right I mean I think you
know if anybody just try to make a
doctor's appointment today you know or
establishes a new patient it's difficult
and so what we don't want people to do
is fail on all the good work that's been
invested you know New Hampshire fulfills
its constitutional responsibility for
treatment within um you know the system
and so you know you don't want it all
that good work and time and effort to to
then result in a bounceback because they
haven't got the medicines and care that
they need
represent thank you and as a followup to
that question uh was I hearing that
during the 45 days when they're still
incarcerated there's also an effort to
make some Community connections so that
upon release which is a big shock they
might actually have already formed a
connection as to where to go to
continue with whatever kind of services
they're needing is that you have it
correct so the intake is terrific Y and
hopefully U also there's a Care
Management component which will be
provided um by the mcos to make sure
like if they need appointments that
those are established before they hit
the street if you will um and you know
we'll be coordinating with the care
coordination that happens within um the
correction system thank you very
much representative Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair um so again I'm I'm just got my
Financial hat on uh the the the adult
community re-entry demonstration looks
like it was our idea and it's a good one
and but it's got a a cost implication
I'm I'm I'm wondering if it's a a net
reduction on state costs or if you think
it's a net increase in state costs I
believe it will be a net reduction that
reduction like with dental when we
talked about that doesn't not going to
happen immediately okay just interested
time that's really all I needed to hear
and then if I may on the second one you
may the same kind of question on the
this the community re-entry
demonstration uh this this looks like an
unfunded mandate that is going to cost
us more money and I'm not talking about
the quality and value of the program I'm
just looking at uh increased demands on
on General funds what this this feels
like an increase in demand on General
funds if so can you give me an idea
rough order of magnitude with the price
tag guess so we're talking about youth
re-entry now the the congressionally
mandated piece yeah so it may relieve
some costs at accting level um it may
relieve some costs in in Corrections um
and again like most of the when you
think about children kids coming on syc
you know we have them typically just for
time I'm just talking about money okay I
would say that net cost again over time
will be less um than what we're spending
today even though it's an unfunded
Federal mandate well the feds are
putting money in um as well um you know
to uh to cover costs uh I think that
since we have them in the program
anyways if we have them in a plann
fashion and we're doing it on a
preventative basis we're going to you
know dealing with people in emergency
rooms dealing with boarding and dealing
with other issues that we deal with I
think the cost of the system as the
state experience it should be less than
what it is uh today and in terms of um
the next uh uh Managed Care contract
Amendment we do have some costs that we
pay out but I think that the the cost
that come back that we don't experience
in the back end will offset that thank
thank you this would be a good PL um ABC
this would be a good B or C conversation
to have offline sure please continue
continue
um so on the on the youth side um the
benefits a little bit different um and
basically there's uh 30 days prior to
release there's basically um the epsdt
basically the screening for um
conditions um and diagnostic services
can be covered um and so like a physical
or or mental health assessment all those
types of things are are um coverable
Services plus after release whether
they're on Medicaid or not they get 30
days of of Care Management um the the
other thing is that you know in Medicaid
the definition of child is under 21 and
the prison system it can be um you know
different they might look at it as 18
the other thing is former foster care
children um up to um the their end of 26
if you will when they turn 26 they lose
it but the former foster care which
nationally they say about 50% of the
children that are in prison have had our
former foster care so making sure that
um they're getting supports as well um
also in our Managed Care Program the
general Managed Care Program we get
there when we repr procured we have
prioritized um uh Managed Care follow up
on this this priority population of
incarcerated individuals to follow them
up for a year to make sure again that
we're we're experiencing the cost at the
lowest level by doing more things on a
preventative
basis representative Merchant thank you
Mr chair it's more of a comment than a
question um I think when you I'm hearing
is that this is more an investment than
an expense um if we're investing in
trying to help the individual get off on
the right foot the long-term payback
could be tremendous is that what I'm
understanding yes I think both for
Corrections and county jails in terms of
recidivism and in Medicaid that that
we're dealing with the problem at the
right level not not in the ER not in
institutions right trying to get you I
may is in Sullivan County we actually
have something called the Sullivan house
because what we found out is that when
you go through all the Investments
whether in carcerated and to get them on
the right foot they end up going back
into the apartment which they came out
of so we actually created the suvan
house in order to help them for another
6 months so expect maybe again if it's
pilot is collecting some data from the
suent house to show what it will mean as
far as that investment if if I could
make one comment I think I can end it
this if you don't have any other
questions is that uh we're already
starting to meet with counties we've met
with Sullivan County um we've met with
six of the 10 so far and we hope in the
next few weeks we'll accomplish the rest
to make an assessment one of the things
the differenti cheting factors here
they'll point out that's in the
presentation is that the the federal
requirement and the waiver all are on
people who are sentenced or adjudicated
so if you're not sentenced which in the
counties can be up to 75% of the
population or more they're not eligible
for the benefit um but and so we have to
work with the counties to make sure that
it the system to provide the medical
services fits with what they're already
doing
may I make a suggestion to you and to
anybody else
listening there are a certain number of
people that I only can convince not on
the basis of whether it's right or
compassionate but that it is saving
money and I can Intuit it that good
things often save money they are truly
Investments but some people need to see
numbers and whether it is something at a
beginning stage here or you make use of
this being implemented in other states
so there is a longitudinal study those
numbers help me sell the
product we do have a requirement under
the 1115 waiver to do a formal
independent evaluation of it um so
there'll be an interim evaluation and um
an evaluation after the five-year waiver
length and we intend um to do evaluation
on the federally required program as
well good looking for bring that
information to you thank you any further
questions no thank you oh Medicaid
schools I think was the other that's
right well would you would you like to
hear that today or do you want to do
that can I have a three and a half
minute
version yes maybe even less
um so thank you have on the clock um I
think um representative Edwards brought
up a concern around um parental uh
knowledge of what's going on um and I'll
differentiate what's going on the
Medicaid schools which may happen in
schools but not related to the Medicaid
schools program the Medicaid schools
program the parent has to sign off on um
the plan of care um and changes in the
plan of care um also in the Medicaid
Program the parent is what we call the
case head the case head is entitled to
get any inform you know we have to
provide the full if they ask for all
their billing information to see what's
going on with their child they they have
a right to access that um and so I
that's I think we talked a little bit
about this at fiscal I don't know if we
need more on that or not so I'll leave
you okay so I I I appreciate that I
understand that I'm still concern
concerned a little bit about this Edge
case where kids age out while still in
school to where they acrew a privacy
right they didn't when they were younger
is is there is there a a a group a
demographic in the uh Medicaid for
school program in which they uh adult
medical privacy rights kick in and the
parents are no longer um in the loop
about what's happening to their care so
as I understand the case head has full
access to the um to the records that you
know the the billing information and
what have you so um
I I think that um that I think that the
the the protections under the Medicaid
school program for Parental parent
wanting to know what's going on are
covered in in several different levels
they have to do the approval initially
of the plan schools don't want to to
because schools have to pay money to
have Medicaid to schools they have to
pay half the cost or um and so you know
they schools are not interested in
picking up extra costs through that
through that mechanism and then um if
there's a change in it there's required
sign off and to Bild Medicaid the parent
has to sign off on um that's not to say
a bad actor if you will might might do
something that isn't right but the
program I think is structured to to
protect parental
rights okay let's move on so so my
editorial comment on that other than
thanking you for following up is is that
uh I I think it's critical in this
environment that the transparent
with the providers and the parents is
maintained at a very high level in order
for there to be faith and credibility in
this program and therefore
sustainability and without it becoming a
a political distraction so I I I I I am
uh glad to hear what your description
and I I just hope we continue
that one final comment there been in the
media this past week about uh local
community struggling and the state
struggling with special education costs
the medical component of that um you
know one of our goals and we talk about
this at another meeting because I'm want
to stay within my three minutes there is
help available through Medicaid to
communities in dealing with some of
their special ed costs and I think we
need to work with them to to uh and we
we have a plan to do that but I know we
don't have time to talk to about good
thank you and not counting
representative Edwards comments I owe
you 22 seconds next time you're here
thank
you um thank you for the great questions
and and uh for inviting such an array of
of updates if you want I can maybe do
the 22nd on the two reports that you
asked uh for feedback on but I guess
what I would just say at a high level
something that struck me listening to my
colleagues is that everything you're
hearing about today as part of our
commissioner's update um or Deputy
commissioner's update today is part of
our DHHS road map that commissioner we
ever presented to you all
and it's about serving people in their
communities um and not in institutional
settings and to that end I want to just
emphasize there are two quarterly
reports that you have one I believe you
have in print here today the other one
um John Williams is going to help me
distribute via email
momentarily um and I just want to give
the the 10 seconds on each of them so
one is the quarterly report on HB 49 um
which is the bill to replace the sen
Services Center um and the big news
there that is in that report that you
have is that we have officially begun um
construction of the new facility that
will be located on the campus that is
shared with Hamstead hospital um We are
continuing to engage extensively to get
community input um stakeholder input and
make sure that this is in line with the
expectations of HB 49 as well as the
important concerns that have come
forward from from local neighbors um
Behavioral Health Advocates Etc so happy
to answer any questions the other report
that you have is on the quarterly report
around HB
1573 which was um sponsored by our own
chairman representative Pearson and is a
bill to allow the department to continue
its work to strengthen oversight of
Youth residential programs um and to
ensure that in those increasingly rare
times that we need to utilize programs
especially those that are further from
New Hampshire um that we are doing so
with a commitment to Quality and to
short-term placement to ensure that kids
are getting back to their homes and
communities um with as many uh supports
and as as promising a future as possible
so really proud of our team and the
progress that they're making on both
fronts building a residential
architecturally secure therapeutically
oriented facility for our Juvenile
Justice population that requires
detention or commitment and also
strengthening our oversight the
residential treatment facilities on
which we will continue to rely less and
less as we come up with Community
Alternatives probably more like 1 minute
and 40 seconds but 1 minute and 23
seconds but who any any questions before
good morning Mr chairman I didn't mean
to be presumptuous and just coming up
but no you were covering for me because
I was trying to find my place and I just
doubted myself but thank you well yeah
we're we'll keep you on track Mr
chairman no worries for the record DJ
beton Court commissioner of the New
Hampshire insurance department Kirk
Williamson the executive director of the
prescription drug affordability
board so we are pleased to join you this
morning to discuss the redundancy
elimination report I would note at the
outset that unfortunately I do apologize
that our uh resident and I say this with
the utmost admiration uh and kindness
our resident data geek Dr Jason AIS who
is the director of our data analytics
unit unfortunately is away today so
you're stuck with me I will highlight
what I think are the uh pertinent
aspects of this report in the best
it do we have a handout of some
sort oh coincidentally
yes all
right got it wonderful so as I was
saying I will do my best to hit what I
think are the highlights in the best
manner possible which is to say the uh
to the extent that I understand all of
this and if Dr AES doesn't like it well
don't go on vacation next time when
they're supposed to be here uh so and
then and then obviously I'll turn it
over you can declare him
redundant certainly not I'm more likely
to be found redundant than him uh but in
any event this report came about as a
result of a legislative request which is
to say you all put it in statute which
required us to do it and so Dr AES and
his team really did throw themselves
into this work Dr azis had the benefit
of also serving as a member of PAB and
so he was able to bring that background
and that experience uh to bear in
putting this together so at its root the
purpose of this report was to identify
and describe relevant oversight and or
regulatory redundancies with regard to
the collection analysis and Reporting on
prescription drug prices among the
Department of Insurance in the New
Hampshire pdab
board I'm pleased to say that to my
reading and my understanding what you
see reflected in this
report is about 80% consensus between
the department and the pdab board there
are some areas of diverging views and
that's perfectly fine at the end of the
day when it comes to this report I take
the same attitude that I take anytime I
appear before a legislative body which
is to say we have put forward what we
think is good work we have put forward
what we think are solid recommendations
at the end of the day it is up to you as
the legislature as the policy makers to
decide what you do and do not want to
consider and or move forward with but
this is the information uh that we've
put before you do with that what you
will and so again some of the highlights
the first Focus was on data collection
and you cannot have that particular
conversation without first acknowledging
the fact that the department has access
as does the Department of Health and
Human Services to an incredibly valuable
tool the all claims database which is
abbreviated to chis so as I've said DHHS
has access to this PAB as the result of
living kind of under the Department of
Health and Human Services also has
access to that data the data that they
may desire via the chis system via the
Department of Health and Human Services
and so the report as you'll see does not
see a reason for pdab to have to collect
data now I will tell you
philosophically that the collection of
data on the one hand is unbelievably
important
but there's a limit to that data in the
sense that you can drown yourself in it
and so what you want to ensure that
you're doing is that you are collecting
data that is getting you toward some
sort of a policy
objective so that's in the first
instance in the second instance you want
to ensure that the individuals who are
taking in and analyzing that data have
the ability to understand it otherwise
you're just getting numbers in you don't
know what it's driving you towards
in the best instance in the worst
instance you don't understand it and
therefore run the risk of having it be
something that you make a decision on or
begin to formulate thoughts around when
you don't actually understand it
so again the report would suggest that
PAB um would have a very very difficult
time if it attempted to try to get into
the data collection
business again under that headline we
would point out the health C tool we
always talk about that it's a great
asset to Consumers as well as to policy
makers and again uh that's a similar
resource that should provide pdab with
the data that it's looking for so again
I understand that there are some who
feel that pdab should have access to Raw
data rather than the data that they
would get via the insurance department
or the Department of Health and Human
Services again that is a decision for
you and the legisl to make as to whether
or not you want to give them that access
again I would highlight two issues the
first is again that comprehension piece
uh how to best understand and interpret
the raw data that you're getting that
may very well be surmountable depending
on the experience of the individual
members making up pdab but you also have
a pretty significant legal consideration
to think through which is a lot of the
raw data that exists Within These
systems is proprietary data and so who
has access to that data is very very
carefully considered and and we'll get
to that in a little bit so the second
big piece of the report surrounds PBM
reporting and I will admit that prior to
the passage of Senate Bill 555 earlier
this
year um the department quite frankly did
not have the tools that we needed to be
able to get information that was useful
not only to all of you as policy makers
but useful to us as a department I was
stunned when the first reporting
requirement under the previous statute
came up and legislators were asking me
for the reports others were asking me
for the reports and I said I need to see
these reports and what I would get back
are these one or two page
attestations that told me absolutely
nothing and therefore we're not going to
be at all helpful to you and Senate Bill
555 thankfully gave us the regulatory
teeth that we need to get the
information from the pbms that is going
to be useful to us and ultimately useful
to all of you as well but as a
consequence of that Senate Bill 555 did
create some redundancies that were not
anticipated prior to the final version
of Senate Bill 555 being finalized in
Nei June or July I can't quite
recall again I would highlight at this
point and this I think is pertinent not
only to this report but I think to the
discussion of PAB and prescription drug
data collection RIT
large believe you me I am very
frustrated sometimes in this position by
the information that I am and am not
legally permitted to
disclose and when you are talking about
PBM related items there is a lot of
protection for proprietary
information in the consequence of
disclosing any of that proprietary
information is that I or any individual
who would disclose it becomes personally
liable personally liable under the law
to suffer the potential
consequences of disclosing information
that I'm not and I can assure you that
the aeton court family budget does not
have the capacity to defend uh any sort
of a prosecution or lawsuit coming from
a PBM or
otherwise and I appreciate the fact that
this generates a lot of frustration a
lot of frustration for the legislature a
lot of frustration for pdab we do the
very best we can to be as transparent
and forthcoming with the aggregated data
that we are permitted to make available
and so again I think those those
proprietary and and privacy protections
are a very pertinent issue that again
crops up not only in terms of this
report but again as it pertains to pdab
as a whole the next item I would
highlight is the drug manufacturer price
reporting the issue there centers around
the fact that both PAB and the insurance
department have the authority to collect
this data the question is a matter of
who is going to do this work and who is
more or I should say who is better
positioned to do this work so the
department right now has the experience
we have the staff we have the resources
to do it if you wanted pdab to do it
that again is your decision and we'll
abide by whatever you decide but it
would require um a lot of staff and a
lot of resources PAB would have to I
would think bring on quite a few people
to come help and so
again that the redundancy there is we
both have the authority that's not a
question the question is who is better
positioned and who would you prefer to
do that
work so uh the last piece of that I
would also mention is that we are
currently required to report this data
to the Board of Pharmacy so if you
decide ultimately that you wanted pdab
to do this work don't forget to uh have
them take on the responsibility for
reporting it over to the Board of
Pharmacy and taking it away from us so I
think I've gone on quite long enough and
I'll turn it over to my colleague here
who is uh much smarter than I am on all
of this so you can ask him all the tough
questions and you can save the easy ones
for me thank you Mr chairman no no no um
thank you all for having me here um I do
want to say um I we really appreciate as
a board being able to collaborate with
the insurance department I think that
was key in getting this report across a
Finish Line
um and collaboration is crucial
particularly with such a nuanced and
complex issue um of such an opaque
nature as prescription drug
prices oh and I can remind you for the
record I'm Kirk Williamson I'm the
executive director of the prescription
drug affordability board I'll say that
the report did serve as an important
moment of reflection I think it allowed
us to systematically look across the
state and see where we are collecting
data where different data is housed
whether it's in the apcd whether it's
contained in the insurance department
and whether the pdab has the existing um
Authority orus in place to access that
data to fulfill its Mission um the board
did vote this year as part of its goals
for 2025 to execute anou with the
insurance department so that we can
eliminate any redundancies and leverage
everybody's shared work um of course
there are protections that would need to
be built in place place um particularly
if we are accessing net price data or
anything around rebates um and I would
say that um you know because this is
such a complex issue that we are
interested in working with all agencies
we have anou in place with HHS so that
we can access chiz data we are um we
have a goal to execute one with the
insurance department which again shows
our uh collaborative nature to tackling
this issue for granite Staters um I
think it's also important to remind the
members that the insurance department
and the PAB play distinct but
complimentary roles um in addressing
prescription drug affordability and I
think our ability to meet we met last
week to discuss a lot of these issues
and I think that through theou we're
able to eliminate any possible
redundancies um and continue this work
um with Vigor um I'll pause there um I
know we've been speaking for a while so
I'm happy to answer any questions
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair and also thank you to both of you
being here today um I'm sort of uh just
for the record I also the chair of the
prescription portability board so I want
to be clear about where I'm coming from
one of the things we talked about before
I think commissioner Benton Court you
talked about this is data
collection when I was at Mary Hitchcock
we started out with every Department not
every a lot of departments collecting
data what we migrated to was a data
warehouse so that we had an entity
within the organization that knew how to
collect data so the Departments would
then work with them to what data they
needed to have and then the data
warehouse would collect the data on
their behalf is there any somewhere in
the state of New Hampshire are we
working towards a comparable data
warehouse because I do agree that
collecting data and how you go about
doing it the process itself can be
honorous and it has to be done correctly
but have redundancy again if we're
having different agencies collecting
data are we not by default creating
redundancy in the data collection versus
having a central Data Warehouse in the
state of New Hampshire well I think a
lot of that depends on which agency has
the authority to collect which data and
which data Falls underneath the mission
statement of the particular agency so
obviously the focus of the insurance
department is different than say the
mission of the Department of Health and
Human Services we have access to
different dat we have different focuses
but I agree with you to have it in one
centralized location is incredibly
beneficial and dare I say efficient and
I think that ultimately that's the ver
that's the vision that we all have for
the all claims database that is database
system and we take it very very
seriously we want that to be an
incredibly useful uh and Powerful tool
for not only the agencies to leverage
But ultimately for all of you to be able
to leverage as well and it's the reason
why when the department did a when the
insurance department did a recent
reorganization of our operations we
created a separate data analytics unit
and part of their mission is to look at
how we can enhance the all claims
database System including how we can
enhance it to collect information around
pbms and prescription drugs so
designating one agency to be the sole
agency that oversees and plugs data into
chin
I think would be problematic for the
reasons I've described but having that
one system I think that's very
beneficial follow up thanks thank you
for that commissioner so I want to be
clear you're not saying that the board
should not have authority to collect
data but you're talking about trying to
find a way to collect the data on behalf
of the
board so I think the question becomes
what do you have the capacity to take on
and if you're going to take on trying to
collect
data I think you need to ensure that
that data is not already being collected
by either the insurance department or
the Department of Health and Human
Services and then how do you navigate
the fact that you're going to need to
bring to be level of expertise to be
able to understand the data that's in
front of you and what legal protections
are you going to put in place should the
data that you're attempting to collect
be considered proprietary I think I
think those are tricky issues to kind of
work through particularly when you have
resources like the expertise you see in
the insurance department and the
Services representative Edwards all
right so we have you surrounded we have
the chair of the pdab here I I'm a I'm a
sitting member of the PAB and I think I
have another four years in my term for
that um and uh I so I've been involved
in this redundancy report for it its
Inception I appreciate all the work I
have worked with Dr ziz he's a great
gentleman very smart too smart sometimes
but um so just I want to summarize break
it down to a simple level uh the result
of the redundancy report is that there
has been identified some redundancies in
the way the pdab was initially
legislated and and what the insurance
department and probably other
Departments of the state are doing so
yes there there are redundancies uh two
I I think some of the redundancies are
significant uh and need to be addressed
and and that this summary uh basically
creates a list of of the significant
ones that but it's not inclusive of all
redundancies this is a summary of the
significant ones I believe is that true
that's correct we wanted to ensure that
I mean the report at this point is
already at Nine Pages we wanted to
provide you with with the ones that we
felt were
most obvious so so so thank you so
knowing that this was coming on uh a few
of us legislators have been getting
together to try to draft a bill a couple
of bills as it turns out to uh
anticipate the trajectory of this
redundance report and to pick up on it
and and try to address some of those
redundancies in law specifically you
know who's going to collect and store
the data and protect the data that that
that's something that uh proposed
legislation is going to include and so
um that that those bills are not uh
ready yet to distribute more widely but
I would love to be able to send uh you
uh and of course Mr Williams you'll just
get it automatically but to to to you Mr
commissioner the our our proposed
legislation so that if if we're Miss if
I'm missing something as the prime
sponsor that you uh shake and let me
know certainly we're happy to do that we
do that for legislators all the time and
I would say philosophically I think
we're all in favor of more efficiency in
government I don't think that's a
controversial position to take but in
terms of the policy decisions those are
yours to make but what I would tell you
representative Edwards is if you say
this is our goal and this is the
language that we think gets us to our
goal myself and uh the experts within
the department will look to make sure
that those two things are in alignment
yeah and and I and I appreciate followup
thanks and I just do appreciate the the
the statement that was made that that in
the last week you've had discussions
about the redundancies and how to ensure
the pdab and the other work done by the
insurance company department and others
are complimentary and not overlapping
and so that's that's really been the
objective of asking for this redundancy
report so so thank you for uh helping us
nail The Landing I hope any further
questions where running behind our
schedule so uh please make them succinct
if you have them didto with the answer
thank you so much for your members of
the
committee Medicaid reimbursement rates
for prosthetic and orthotic devices
update report Mr Henry Lipman and Mr
Henry Lipman and you have all the time
you need plus about 22 seconds more but
be
brave and turn on your
mic thank you very good so the report I
provided I gave you a paragraph by
paragraph what's in the law and how we
complied with it um we we have complied
um I happy to take any questions the the
fee schedule update is attached to the
report um and
um I think it was just to make sure that
we did what we were supposed to do and I
did so do you want to take over Vice
chair well sure yeah representative
Edwards um I this is a question for
representative Weber actually uh do do
you recall who wanted this report and if
if if you think it meets the
requirements of the of the person asking
for it I don't I don't
recall I don't I don't so I don't I'm
sorry about that um I I remember that we
had the discussion um um but and I'm I'm
glad to have the
information
um I'm trying to recall whether it was
in the context of a bill that we had in
front of us at at Health and Human
Services and I think that that's
probably the Genesis of it but I'm very
sorry right at the moment I'm not
remembering um perhaps director lipin
remembers what I remember how the 90%
came about and how was represent H um if
I'm pronouncing his name correctly
suggested that the 9% be tied to the
January 1st uh January 2024 rate for
Medicare at the time and that's that's I
think it probably came about uh that
confirming that that's what we did and
welcome yes public awareness campaign on
brain health Alzheimer's disease related
dementias now uh this is from the
um which group the Bureau of adult and
Aging Services
okay um let me see I'll just show you
the handout we have
the uh annual report for the public
awareness campaign and then we do have a
slide Deck with brain health campaign
activities listed at the front um that
have uh again uh Wendy Alman the bureau
chief of the Bureau of adult and Aging
Services and I have here um a partner uh
Jennifer Horan I'll let her introduce
herself
thank you uh Jenny Horan senior public
policy director for the alarmers
association and we sprung you out of the
Senate you sure did
yeah so um in front of you today is um
information just to give you a progress
update on the brain health campaign and
um what we've been able to accomplish
over this last year what I'd like to
focus on is the uh brain health campaign
activities we have been since our last
update uh in front of the committee we
were um able to make progress on a um
pre campaign survey um and we were able
to review those results we also uh
engaged in um developing an ambassador
committee which really is made up of
individuals who are um either uh living
with some form of Al Alzheimer's disease
or Rel ated Dementia or family members
really to give feedback on campaign work
um as well as members of the
subcommittee for Alzheimer's disease
disease and related dementia um they
will be involved in helping with the
media campaign materials and work so if
you were to look at the slide deck we
are able to provide you with um some of
the activities that we're currently uh
working on and timeline um for all of
those activities over the next couple of
months so we will be creating a campaign
web page that will be part of the DHHS
website we will create a public campaign
material uh portfolio which includes
radio TV and print digital and social
media ads as well as a series of health
professional materials um that will be
digital social and video as well as
brochure
um we included in the slide deck a
sample of what some of those materials
look like based on the work that we've
done with our workg group um which
includes the Commission on
Aging uh members of our Communications
office at the department as well as uh
subcommittee members and other partners
within the
community uh this is a example of print
communic materials which is a brochure
to promote uh brain health and we also
then on the next page have the the media
ads and uh the general public uh
campaign that will be taking place and
the timeline in which that will happen
over the next couple of months within
the state fiscal year and uh the reach
um in terms of The Impressions and and
Views that we expect to get from this
campaign the uh toolkit that we will be
creating for our strategic Partners will
also be developed and there will be a
plan for dissemination and Outreach to
Community Partners including senior
centers
libraries area agencies and medical uh
medical facilities and
others um we do expect at the end of the
campaign to have a final report on the
media work um and the partner and
Outreach achievements that we were able
to um see as well as a post campaign
survey uh we will compare our pre survey
work um with individuals and conduct a
post campaign survey to gauge uh
performance in terms of uh level of
knowledge um awareness and intent to
look at the success of the campaign
and I'm happy to answer any questions
people have um and happy to catch the
agenda up if there aren't any questions
any questions looking around
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair I think I think I have two one one
one is um uh was was this the funds to
set this up uh I I seem to recall it
being uh positioned as one-time money
and I don't remember if it was Federal
art money or something but but is was
this in the budget as a one-time
investment or or is it
ongoing uh currently this campaign and
the work that we're doing to
operationalize it was funded through hb2
and it's 100% General funds and it was
in the amount of 500,000 500,000 okay
just follow up follow up and I I think
at the time that we were doing this um
and this may be for Dr hen um is is that
uh we we made the observation that this
program was going to get set up under
your department and that we tried to
encourage that you work with the public
health people who had a similar public
facing Mission and that in this next
budget cycle that we were looking at one
public facing uh advertising Marketing
Group in DHHS and not proliferate in
multiple departments or
where are we at with making sure that
we're aligned and and and we're pinning
the rows on one
entity um I I'll I'll start and then if
MCA has anything to add she can add um
many of the materials that we're looking
to produce can be uh reproduced um and
be done in an ongoing basis because it
is brain health um we do expect that
we'll have some coordination and
collaboration with Public Health in
terms of any um resources or funding
that we can collaborate on between both
our Bureau and uh population Health
within
dph okay so what so so what I think I
just heard you say is that you'll
continue to remain the subject matter
experts to update the materials but that
the people who are responsible for
coordinating the Contracting and
development and distribution and website
for for the materials is going to be
Public
Health um I would I would expect that it
would be a partnership between um no I'm
looking for roles and responsibilities
not Partners but but thank you I think I
I got
it any other
questions thank you for coming thank you
report and Jessica Gorton director DL
TSS
Services good morning Jessica Gorton
bureau chief for the Bureau of
Developmental
services so I am here today to give you
all an update on our quarter 4 weit list
you should have a report in front of you
unfortunately mine is in color yours is
in black and white but it does have the
should be titled developmental
disabilities acquired brain disorder yes
that is the
one
okay
so as we come again and Report out to
this committee we still continue to have
no funding weight list but as this
committee has expressed an interest as
well as the bureau um of Developmental
Services we really want to try to focus
on who is actually getting those
services that have been funded what are
the reasons that they might not be are
they getting full Services partial
services and we really continue to hone
our data as some of you may recall last
year the New Hampshire lead system that
we utilized in partnership with our area
agencies was sunset necessarily due to
some system issues and we transition to
a state operated system New Hampshire
easy or sometimes you'll hear it
referred to as new heights this is where
the information is now logged stored and
we are starting to get um I'm proud to
say we are starting to get additional
and helpful data to start to isolate and
Target initiatives and give us
information on where we can best align
resources and focus efforts and getting
people access to their services um also
on June 28th or July 1st uh right in
that time period we rolled out a couple
of pretty significant it enhancements
that we had mentioned the last time we
came and presented um one was a provider
View and access ACC to our New Hampshire
easy portal so that they could see the
status of those authorizations for
services those um that requirement that
allows them to bill and be paid for
services rendered in addition we've
automated the start dates as well um in
capturing that data so it's no longer a
manual process so based on that service
authorization once that's entered the
start date is also now logged so that we
can start to get more timely data um
more point in time data rather on when
Services
begin also working in partnership with
our area agency staff the entry of these
delay reasons we've presented and
discussed in in previous committee
meetings that this was a manual process
and given the amount of work and the
effort that everyone in our service
system was putting forth in prioritizing
those payments for services to get
individuals faster access to Services we
delayed the the manual entry of those
Del reasons but as of July 1st we've
started uh working and entering that
data and it is starting to come in so
that we can now include that information
on the report that you have in front of
you so with that said I'll dive into the
report data if that's okay all right so
for our developmental disabilities
waiver which is our largest waiver we in
quarter 4 had 100 individuals who
requested to start
Services um nine individuals withdrew
the request which can happen sometimes
so of those 91 remaining individuals 86
were projected to start their services
within the quarter of those 86 25 began
their services and the remaining 61 that
did not start their services had delay
reasons that are laid out within the
report the top three being their in
trying to secure a provider agency find
a a provider who is able to offer those
services in the way the individual was
looking for them um individual and
family request I I will say given the
quarter being quarter 4 because a lot of
the folks who are newly requesting
services are transitioning out of school
it's not uncommon to see a request to
delay Services until maybe after the
summer um and then the other reason is
um folks attempting to access the
Medicaid benefit going through the
application process and making sure
everything gets put
through looking at our inhome support
waiver for children and young adults who
are still in the school district and
accessing services within their family
home there were 10 folks who asked
accessed um excuse me requested funding
and who were funded um of those nine be
began their services and one individual
did not start Services due to an
individual in family
request and on our required brain
disorder waiver one individual requested
Services uh excuse me requested funding
and we did fund that individual they
were pending their Medicaid benefit to
begin so they had not started services
within the
quarter so as you know we've discussed
us really looking at how do we get in
there the the top reason really does
remain as it's reported both anecdotally
from family service coordinators and as
our data is starting to show we're
continuing to struggle in the area of
Workforce so the department has put
forward a number of Workforce grants
totaling over $155 million as well as
over $7 million to service coordinators
or case managers in our service delivery
system to try to infuse some funding
into efforts around um Workforce
retention and
recruitment um our Service Coordination
agencies and the bureau have focused
efforts on ensuring service
authorizations were in place um this is
a reason that in past meetings we have
reported was also impacting delay and
we're really proud to say that through
partnership and work with our area
agencies our Service Coordination
agencies and the bureau as of the
writing of this report only three
service authorizations were over 14 days
and waiting for the bureau to have an
initial review of that so the data is
starting to really help both in getting
folks access to services but also in our
ability to prioritize and organized
workload so that we have that view on
what's coming in and and make sure that
we're getting that work done as quickly
as possible on the bureau side as well
um we continue to facilitate ongoing
meetings with our Service Coordination
agencies our provider agencies and now
our intake coordinators at our area
agencies so that we can all exchange
information talk about workflow talk
about the data and what enhancements
might be needed within the it system it
it's been a great process and moving
into this data um in this database and
as we get data it shows us what we would
also like to see different ways to slice
and dice and um put those requests in
and try to uh find additional
opportunity for us to just efficiently
View and organize the
workload representative representative
Edwards uh uh thank you uh I I I think
this may be the most spectacular thing
I've seen coming out of the state in all
of 2024 because we had been asking for
the real weight List information for
what 3 years now something like that and
so you've accomplished something that uh
is just wonderful uh to know that and
and it isn't just that you've gotten it
done it feels like you have pretty
strong data confidence that you know the
data is real and and that you you've
developed a work plan on how to continue
to improve it so that's all excellent uh
I would just recommend you include a
point of contact in the report to to
take credit for all the good work and to
and to get the occasional uh ad a boy
and you know supplemental question but
but uh thank thank thank seriously thank
you three years of asking for this I
would also want to say thank you because
earlier in my time in the house I had
been quite active working with area a
couple of area agencies and so on and
there was this
frustration uh on the part of individual
citizens that they weren't being heard
they didn't have a chance I don't hear
that much I mean there's always going to
be some people who say that but I I find
it's in a manageable amount now compared
so again thank you and um what's your
contact information because it's not in
my phone I will bring some business
cards up shortly that I can bring some
business cards up short great yeah I
love cards thank you any other questions
yes representative Weber so now that we
have all this great data and I I add my
thanks to everybody else's I'm wondering
if um you could elaborate a little bit
on the no current Medicaid open category
because that seems to be one of the
roadblocks and is that a matter of
people needing help to finish the
application process uh or is is are
there things that you see that we could
be doing to facilitate getting that
category down cuz I understand the other
ones sometime if the people aren't there
they're aren't there but yeah it it
could be for a number of reasons um
folks sometimes will um apply and maybe
not offer the the verifications or the
documents that the Medicaid office needs
to determine if that individual might be
eligible particularly around the look
back requirement if folks have heard
that terminology and looking at those
assets over the last several years um in
some cases you know folks maybe need
some support in filing those
applications and we've been able to
create really strong collaboration and
partnership with our Bureau of family
assistance and also with the service
link aging and disability Resource
Centers um overseen by my colleague
Wendy and making sure that folks have
access to those supports too if they
need just a little extra you know some
arms wrapped around them and the
application process to help them
navigate that and what can often be a
very trying point in time in their life
so we understand more supports are
needed those are typically the reasons
we see that delay thank you you're
welcome thank you very much for that any
further questions thank you M Gordon
appreciate thank you so much take
care
now a report update regarding the use of
restraint and the use of different modes
of transportation of patients to New
Hampshire hospital or other designated
receiving facilities and in the matter
of full disclosure my younger son
Michael Pearson is a corrections officer
a full uh maximum security uh place in
New York state and does a lot of
prisoner transport so uh this is a
subject I'm kind of interested and it
will come up over the Thanksgiving
table
yes good morning this is I'm Cynthia
babonis I'm the chief of community
hospital and good morning my name is
Caroline Lavoy I'm the VP of data
analytics at the new hsh Hospital
Association and can you hear me okay I
know I'm soft it can get better it can
get better it's good but
that's closer to the microph okay thank
you playground
voice well good morning thank you for
having us um I before I dive into the
report in front of you which is titled
the New Hampshire patient transport and
restraint data do you want to give just
a brief bit of background on why we are
here talking about this report today so
any any patient in New Hampshire who is
designated inv voluntary emergency
admission or iea must be transported
from the emergency room which they are
seen to either New Hampshire hospital or
one of the other six designated
receiving facilities throughout the
state there they will get the
appropriate inpatient psychiatric
treatment that they need historically
before 2020 all these transports were
done by law enforcement but Senate Bill
177 gave the explicit option of using an
ambulance in addition to the option of
law enforcement and the idea there was
to reduce the use of restraints in these
transports and the associated trauma
with that um while keeping the safety of
everyone involved at top of
mind so now a provider um who designates
an IA gets to choose whether law
enforcement or ambulance is appropriate
and then the uh transport agency
themselves ultimately gets to decide if
restraint usage is appropriate in that
case so this is now the fifth report
that we are presenting to this uh
committee um all the law also said that
all the drfs had to report on a yearly
basis their data to this committee that
included the number of transports broken
down by age type of transport and
restraint
usage uh none of the drfs reported Data
before 2020 so we have anything to
compare to before the law went into
effect so this like I said this is the
year five report and this represents
September or October 2023 excuse me to
September
2024 um the top of page one you can see
there is a bit more background
information on the law as well as a
stakeholder group that came together uh
to give input to this process at the
bottom we see some summary statistics
for the year so we had
1251 ieas that's an average of 104 per
month 99% were adults there were only
four child transports for this year 40%
of transports went by ambulance 59% by
law enforcement and the remaining few is
in other category and that's almost
always a family member or facility staff
member transporting the patient a little
less than half of transports occurred
without restraints there are a handful
full of unknowns um and the breakdown of
type of restraints used the majority
were either waist belt or a
combination top of page two you can see
all the transports uh broken down by drf
and by month just to give you a sense of
volume the following sections give a
summary on the mode of transportation
restraints used um usage and the type of
restraints used but you can see more
detail in the appendix if you are
interested so for motive transportation
again since 99% were uh adults and this
is for adults only we're seeing the same
breakdown of 40% ambulance and roughly
60% law enforcement but there is some
variation from month to month throughout
the
year uh restraint application really
depends heavily on the type of uh motor
Transportation you're in so 86% of law
enforcement transports used restraints
were compared to ambulance there were
only two cases of restraints used
throughout the entire
year and on page four you see the
visualization of the types of restraints
used um again no one is overwhelmingly
used but the waist belt and the
combination were the most heavily um
favored for child transports again there
were only four four the whole year three
by ambulance one by law enforcement with
no restraints used in any of the
cases on page five uh and six have
provided some trending data for you to
see um how different metrics have
progressed over the Year we're over the
years we're really not seeing a lot of
variation we did see a slight increase
in the number of transports in year five
partly due to the fact all New Hampshire
hospitals hard work they were able to
open the 12 additional beds back in
April of this year okay and the last
page um again a couple visualizations
just to show you the trends uh over the
year of all ieas by month and then
restraint usage between ambulance and
law enforcement transports over the 5
years as well and then the appendix
follows that so I no just thre a lot of
numbers at you to take any questions on
this
data representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair uh really nice report I I on page
three um in the second line it says that
the uh restraint application that that's
going to tell this report will tell us
whether the application was before or
during transfer and then when I look at
the key I I can see the before transport
but not sort of the dur during transport
I see start only I I I don't know if
that's meant to be the indicator for
restraints added during trans transport
thank you for that question yes let me
clarify so before transport that's the
vast majority that means restraints were
applied to the patient before and then
Remain the whole time um there was one
case of restraints applied at the
beginning and then apparently removed
during transport which is an option that
they had that was what was reported to
me right I'm just I'm yes please I'm
just pointing out uh that the narrative
says or during transfer and there's no
legend that tells us if if it was done
during transport I there's a there's a
conflict between the words and the
legend is what I'm trying to say than
inartfully and then follow up follow up
and then I'm looking at the the graph on
page six bottom right yep uh it looks
like uh this data is from 2020
2024 and as I look at the relationship
between restraint used and transport yes
or no it it feels at first glance that
it's a conflict with the data on page
three because page three seems to
indicate that we have a tremendous
amount of no restraint when you count
the
ambulances and that this chart doesn't
seem to reflect the ambulance lack of
restraint right so on the left on the
bottom of page six is the ambulance so
it's showing almost 100 100% oh okay
that's my fault I I was looking for a
blended um graph and and you didn't put
one there so thank you for the
clarification you're welcome thank you
representative Merchant I'll make it
quick thank you Mr chair in regards to
the discrepancy or or the variance you
should say between law enforcement
restraints of the ambulance can you
speak to what is driving that is it
because of the nature of the person
being transported it's because of the
philosophical or the the way somebody
approaches transportation in other words
it's law enforcement more likely to use
restraints because it's kind of the way
their DNA is structured or is it more
because of the way the person who's
inside of the law enforcement
transportation is requiring it trying to
understand which is driving
it I can't speak with certainty on
what's driving it but as a clinician and
and someone who works at New Hampshire
hospital um the emergency rooms decide
whether they're going to call an
ambulance or um the sheriff's department
and clinicians are going to um lean into
calling law enforcement for more acute
and potentially violent person to begin
with um and so I mean there could be
also some bias in law enforcement to
tend to want to always use restraints
but it's already skewed by the fact that
the emergency room has decided that
they're not calling an ambulance because
this person's too potentially violent
for an ambulance thank you
representative Weber and just as a
comment when when we drafted the
legislation that was the subject of a
significant amount of uh discussion and
compromise and listening to everybody so
we felt that the clinician at the
emergency room was in the best place to
assess
what would be in the best in their
clinical opinion in the best interest of
the person being
transported but the folks doing the
transporting got to decide on the level
that they felt comfortable with for both
the safety of the patient and the safety
of their personnel which was a of great
concern to everybody so that that's kind
of the way the decisionmaking tree came
out and obviously I think the clinical
decision at the at the emergency room
level would drive some of the
assumptions about what was needed in
terms of restraint for for uh
transport representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman um so in
terms of designated receiving facilities
in the state there's seven of them is
that
correct um followup followup yeah uh
cypress center where is that located
yeah Manchester Manchester okay and
another followup Mr followup um so it
seems like and and understandably this
is pretty much the population centers of
the state but the western side of the
state the nor more northern areas uh
what happens up there they have to be
transported to Franklin or something
like that or
to um I'm not but they'll they'll be so
the way that um the care traffic control
team works now at New Hampshire hospital
we receive all the IIA referrals and we
make referrals out to what we feel would
be the most appropriate drf and we do
take into consideration how close that
drf is to that patient's home and to
your point there are fewer available
drfs in the North Country um and so you
know and we also have to take into
consideration the weight for any
particular bed I we don't want someone
waiting in the emergency room longer
than necessary and so we want to move
them to a drf bed as soon as possible
but um yeah there are some part areas
geographically in the state that don't
have as many drf beds available one more
followup yes followup are there thoughts
about perhaps developing anything in the
more Western areas or northern areas or
is that that maybe down the road the
state's always open to other facilities
who want to apply for certification as a
drf thank you and just to add to that um
Dartmouth is opening for Dr is there
four drf
beds five thank you five drf beds um in
the next couple of months Marissa so
yeah so at least we'll have a few more
in the Dartmouth area thank you
representative Weber I will just say
that it is um a matter of some grief to
me but uh Cheshire Medical Center had an
8-bed psychiatric unit and when our
psychiatrist retired we were unable my
understanding is that the hospital was
unable to find another individual to
take on the job of supervising that unit
and the unit has now obviously been
repurposed to something else and it's um
it's a real loss to the to the um
Southwestern portion of the state but
is no further questions have anything
New Hampshire State Commission on Aging
annual
yes uh hello good morning thank you for
having us today my name is Rebecca Sky
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire State Commission on Aging and
with me is Lori duve she is the vice
chair chair-elect of the Commission on
Aging um Sue Ruka unfortunately is out
with health issues um Lori Duff is the
director of Senior Services Easter Seals
and we're very grateful to have her on
the
[Music]
commission so I thought I would
start
report and start with a little bit of a
brief history on the commission so the
commission was established during the
2019 legislative session the key charge
for the commission is to advise the
governor and legislature on policy and
planning related to aging we study areas
of public policy
and that impact older adults and
annually produce a report on our
findings that includes recommendations
for change the report is just one way in
which we carry out our charge we also
have a fabulous newsletter that is
edited by a volunteer that uh comes into
your inboxes um every month it also goes
out to many New Hampshire citizens who
find it of
value and um so in a in a brief time I'm
going to give an overview of the
organization of the annual report
priority recommendations for the
upcoming session and areas where
discussions by policy makers such as
yourselves uh are needed to develop
consensus so if you'd like to follow
along with me on page three um is a
message for myself and the outgoing
chair of the commission zuka the key
message that's in there is that New
Hampshire right now is experiencing a
significant demographic shift whereby
our communities are increasingly compre
comprised of more older adults and fewer
younger people the shift is not only
happening fast but it is a permanent
change to the makeup of our communities
it's not just baby boomers aging it is
driven by declining birth rates and
people living longer lives and it's a
trend that's not going away so it's time
for um New Hampshire's older for all of
us to start seeing New Hampshire's older
adults as a as a valuable natural
resource our state has we can amplify
the opportunity through reforming our
systems of care employment models e um
housing and transport ation options and
harnessing the economic engine and
talents of our in increasingly capable
older
residents so page five uh includes the
vision mission and values of the
commission and list the commission
members who were um at who were on the
people on the Comm who were on the
commission at the time this vote was
reported upon um page six highlights the
activities of the Commission on Aging
over the past year and Page seven Begins
the dive into the priorities new ham uh
the Commission on Aging has identified
for New Hampshire
these are the same four priorities that
we had last year it's strengthening
systems of care for healthy aging it is
growing the Direct Care Workforce it is
advancing age-friendly policy systems
and environments and calling for the
development of a multi- sector plan for
Aging in in New Hampshire what we're
calling an age well NH
plan so in the next Pages we um for each
priority we make a case for the priority
and then we list recommendations for
policy changes that will strengthen our
state uh for reference it's those parts
are in uh those pages are outlined have
a blue box that outlin the
recommendations many of the
recommendations do have a price tag
others um have less of an economic
impact for instance one of the
recommendations under the system of care
is to make the life um safety
inspections and the um complaint uh
finding um complaint reports with
findings um publicly available in
assisted living facilities like is
already available for nursing
facilities so starting on page 24 we
highlight the progress made on each
priority over the last year um some are
programmatic exp uh advances but there's
a larger emphasis on the changes um that
are result of um changes made by the
legislature to public policy so page 34
starts our appendices appendix B on page
35 provides an overview um provides
overview comments made at the 2024
long-term care Sumit in Portsmith by two
economists looking at how long-term
services and supports are funded in our
state it also includes additional
research by the commission uh to round
out the information that was provided um
this appendix calls for policy makers to
look at diversifying funding streams for
Medicaid programs that provide long-term
services and supports to low-income
individuals the Confluence of a larger
older adult population and increasing
trends of poverty amongst older adults
creates the potential for a larger pool
of eligible individuals and suggests
significant more dollars will be needed
down the road for these
programs appendix C the final two pages
of the report provides a demographic
snapshot of the older adult population
in New Hampshire the projection chart on
the bottom of page 40 might be of
greatest greatest interest it really
shows the growth of the older adult
population that is expected here in New
Hampshire um and that data was developed
by the Department of Business and
economic affairs
um now I'm going to turn the uh the
microphone over to Lori Duff who's going
to take a little bit more of a deeper
plan the first priority I want to speak
about is um strengthening the system of
care for healthy aging um a system of
healthy of care for healthy aging was
established in House Bill 2 during the
2023 legislative session looking at a
particular page no no sir no um you
could um it would be
page
eight this recognized that there are an
array of needs a person might experience
as they age here in the granite state
and then ensuring the availability of
services was in our best interest the
changes made in that house bill too have
been helpful towards Shifting the
Reliance on long-term supports and
services facility-based care such as
nursing
homes which is the most expensive
setting for care to more Home and
Community Based
care continuing to strengthen the
accessibility of these services will
continue to support a shift away from
facility based care avoid unnecessary
hospitalizations and improve quality of
life for older adults in need of support
and their
caregivers there are a number of good
ideas uh you'll see on page 10 and 11 to
strengthen the system of care given that
this is a very tight budget year we
trust that you will see the importance
of this and attend that the Bureau of
aging and adults Services budget in
particular the person centered
counseling funds and in the prioritized
needs budget choices for independent
rate increases amounts based on required
rate study per the last house bill to
support CFI rates Guardianship Services
to address increase in demand for slots
and increase in reimbursement
rates there are not enough Guardians in
the state congregate housing
continuation of programs funded via
chapter 79 laws of
2023 going to discuss now the second
priority in the Council on AG's report
is to grow the Direct Care
Workforce we all know of the workforce
crisis our state is experiencing the
commission focuses on the Direct Care
Workforce because as often low wage
workers they have unique needs that are
larger than Workforce initiatives that
that aren't attended to and they are
critical to the well-being of many older
adults it doesn't matter how deep your
pokets are to pay for privately pay
privately for Services New Hampshire
does not have enough workers willing and
able to provide the care data cited on
page 11 suggests that new New Hampshire
has 28 home home healthcare workers per
1,000 adults age 65 and older compared
to the US average of 61 workers per
1,000 adults age 65 and older on page 13
and
14 provide suggestions for growing this
Workforce likely you will see this
session a Workforce Omnibus Bill that
includes ideas for investments into all
types of healthcare workers including
direct care
workers another initiative addressing
this issue is New Hampshire needs
caregivers out of consideration for time
I'll point to Pages 16 and 17 for policy
recommendations that will serve to
support the financial well-being of
older adults by helping them to stay in
the workforce
longer address New Hampshire's housing
challenges with innovative ideas for
expanding needed housing options for
both the older adults and the workforce
housing improving Community
Transportation expanding utilization of
age Tech to stay in homes longer and
increasing Civic
engagement and mostly decreasing social
isolation the final call to action in
the report is for policy makers to
Advocate the concept of developing a
multi- sector plan on Aging while what
we call Ag well New Hampshire
plan what we've done in this report is a
start based on the study the Commission
on Aging has done but we need to have a
larger audience policy makers like
yourself participate in a 10-y year
visioning process to address the impacts
of the rapidly changing demographics our
state is
experiencing to best take advantage of
the opportunities of this change as well
as to address the
challenges we will be approaching the
new governor to create an executive
order calling for this multi- sector
plan on
Aging we hope that you will see the need
as well and also call for the
participation in this
planning we will be reaching out to you
over the coming year to learn your
ideas of what would make New Hampshire
an even better place to
age and we hope that you reach out to
your constituents to be asking a similar
question the more prepared we are the
more resilient we will be we're happy to
questions representative
Merchant uh thank you for this report
and thank you Mr chair take the
question I really have a passion for
this um for multiple reasons but one of
the things I'm looking for is the
demographics and you talk about that
earlier when you look at the
demographics um and we have such a
disparity between the elderly and the
ones behind them providing the service
is there any thought or place that
people can go because many times a
spouse could become a caregiver somebody
in the family could become a caregiver
is a way for them to be compensated for
some of the work that they're doing and
then also is there any funds available
to help them stay in their home either
bathroom facilities um ramps getting
into the house it's very expensive to go
to institutional care they don't want to
go there is very costly so what can we
do to help offset some of that
cost um do you want to answer the first
part about um funds for pay
for yes current currently um there are
funds um through the choices for
Independence program um that enables um
a loved one or a a family member or a
friend to be paid um through that U that
program to take care of an individual
there's no other Pro there's no other
program other than than that one that is
currently paying um and they um are um
the individual needs to be high the
family member or friend needs to be
hired by um um an employer that is
providing that service um and then they
get a certain number of hours um that's
that's provided to them so that but that
is the only one that I'm aware of that's
that's happening for caregivers so like
so Easter sales is does do that yes and
um regarding the second question about
home modification um you know there are
other states that do put more funds into
home modification I I'd actually if
possible um if Wendy might be willing
just to talk a little bit about it the
commission itself is a 26 member
commission that does has representation
from eight state agencies um I do know
that DHHS um what had um utilized some
covid funds uh during the pandemic to
for a home modification program that the
people who were participating in the CFI
program were able to take advantage of
um I don't know about the continuation
of those funds um uh I see Wendy shaking
her head um I also know that there are
some other programs I know um chesher
County um sees the benefit of helping of
helping people to stay in their
communities and so um they have um
dedicated some of their own County funds
to that purpose um um you know it's a
referral program through uh uh social
service agencies that that um allow
people to get access to those funds to
do some home notifications but it's a
it's a it's an area where our state
needs to do have a lot whole lot more
development
happening representative Weber and and
in full disclosure I am the chesher
county uh member of the Commission on
Aging uh and in our County it became
clear to us that um investment in home
care saves us a lot of expenditure in
nursing home care and I guess my
question to you is
um is in part the purpose of the multis
sector plan on Aging HL New
Hampshire uh a way of creating something
that is in the same nature as our tenure
Mental Health Plan where we are planning
Beyond an individual
bium and as as we heard in a number of
areas earlier today the argument and the
documentation for the expenditure of
certain funds
upfront which will then be an investment
that
provides significant savings down the
road because with a
2year banial budget
it's
always easiest to look at what's going
on right now and not plan for how we can
leverage advantages going
forward um that's that's absolutely
correct um and that that's a little bit
of the point of that appendix B that I
pointed out is is that um there is going
to be increasing needs and uh increasing
strains on our our programs and services
and and we need to look further out than
two years we need a 10-year vision and
and and that uh creates bench marks
along the way that um towards uh the
change that we we need to have in our
state uh and we can't turn on and off
that light switch uh there needs to be
along you have two
minutes no I just want to make in this
part of the room not over over there
somehow okay Mr chairman I just want to
make a public comment that has been a
privilege and an
committee and in the legislative body so
thank
you and both to you and to
representative King thank you so much
for your service don't throw out your
lawn signs just in
case thank you
and with that we're finished thank you
and because you've been so wonderful I'm